Don Brennan told the House Intelligence
Committee yesterday he grew increasingly
worried last year about contact between
members of the Trump campaign and
Russian officials talking about his
general experience in
counterintelligence Brennan went on to
say frequently individuals who go along
a treasonous path do not even realize
they're along that path until it gets to
be a bit too late
Nancy Cordes watched the whole thing and
this morning is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning you know
sometimes these officials can be a lot
more candid after they leave government
and that was certainly the case with
Brennan on Tuesday on the other hand a
current top intelligence appointee was
much less forthcoming when he was
grilled about whether President Trump
pressured him to downplay the
investigation I don't feel it's
appropriate to characterize discussions
and conversations with the president the
Director of National Intelligence
repeatedly refused to say what the
president asked of him and of NSA
director Mike Rogers have you talked
about this issue with Admiral Rogers I
am um would like to withhold that
question at this particular point in
time former CIA director John Brennan
told a House committee Tuesday that he
saw a troubling pattern emerge last year
involving the Trump campaign I was a
worried by a number of the contacts that
the Russians had with us persons by last
July
he had set up an interagency task force
comprised of agents from the CIA FBI and
NSA I know what the Russians try to do
they try to suborn individuals and they
try to get individuals including US
persons to act on their behalf either
wittingly or unwittingly the former CIA
chief now a private citizen admitted he
doesn't know where the investigation
stands now these are contacts that might
have been totally totally innocent and
benign as well as those that might have
succumbed somehow to those Russian
efforts the White House seized on that
comment saying the hearings show that
there is still no evidence of any Russia
Trump campaign collusion
I saw information intelligence that was
worthy of invest
by the bureau to determine whether or
not such cooperation of conclusion was
taking place the Senate Intelligence
Committee hit former national security
adviser the fired Michael Flynn with
more subpoenas yesterday they want
specific documents from two of his
businesses and if he continues to
stonewall they say he could be held in
contempt of Congress yeah Thank You
Nancy